جرائم ضد الاطفال صدمت المجتمع المصري
والجاني اخر من تتوقعه هو الام
المتهمه هنا من طبقات وثقافات ومستويات
اجتماعيه مختلفه ما اثار الشكوكا في قاعده
ان الام او النساء الاصلح لحضانه الاطفال
شوفوا الاول الام دي ايه ولا الاب ده ايه
وظروفه ايه ونفسيته ازاي وبعد على الاساس
ده بيكرره لكن الام تلقائي كده لا
ايه يا فرحت لما هتروح للاب في الاب فاسد
ايه اللي انا استفدته
جرائ التي شهدتها السنوات الماضيه اهمها
ارضاء العشيق او زوجي الجديد وهي جرائم
عزاها البعض لوجود خلل نفسي وعقلي لدى تلك
النساء اخر القضايا كانت مع اليوتيوبر هبه
السيد المعروفه بام زياد التي تم القبض
عليها وحبسها بعدما نشرت مقطع فيديو تروي
فيه تفاصيل مشاهدتها لاطفالها وهم يمارسون
افعالا فاضحه وتواجه تهمه استغلال اطفالها
للمصالح الشخصيه او التجاريه في يناير من
عام 2022
قامت سيده مطلقه وعشقها بقتل طفلتها
لارضاء العشيق الذي طلب التخلص منها بسبب
بكائها المتكرر
في الاسره شوف اني الطرف الافضل لحضانه
تبقى معاه المفروض الحضانه تروح للام
مباشره لان دي طبيعه الاشياء الام هي اكثر
حنانا واكثر عطفا على الصغير سبتمبر
الماضي حاله النيابه العامه في القليوبيه
سيده للمحاكمه امام الجنايات بتهمه قتل
طفلتها والشروع في قتل بقيه اطفالها ثلاثه
بمساعده عشيقها لاجبار زوجها على تطليقها
قضايا دفعت بمطالبه بعض الخبراء
القانونيين بضروره تعديل حق الحضانه
التلقائيه للام بعد الطلاق والمنصوص عليه
بالقانون الحالي في حاله الطلاق لصباح
العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات